good evening the emergency vacuous
evacuation announcement
are we all aware of that that's politics
for absence we've had qualities from
Nick Cooper in the office any others on
cap stories any others right substitute
members got counseling this is going for
counselor ease yeah any non members
attending no minutes of the meeting held
on the 27th of November 2018
I told five to receive declarations of
interest by our name okay so we'll go on
to item 6 which is the external auditor
report subject to 2017 18 and we have to
consider a report the assistant director
of democratic services
setting out the current position on the
external auditors recommendations
arising from the 1718 audit results we
brought to the audit committee and I
think Jim's going to do that Thank You
mr. This report provides an update of
the positions related to
[Applause]
so your noise signatures yes our two
sakes so the uncertainty on
recommendations just a few of those and
their responses to those metals all must
be our ally the 302nd page go to page
six point two three the first one
achievement achievement of savings
needed over the medium-term the
recommendation starts off in the Box we
recommend for transparent for
transparency to the public but the int
MTFs and it goes on to survey so you
know obviously looking at the word
transparency and then I'm gonna show
them the only response we are we as a
counselor doing emergency response
so first there are community profiles
profile the base budget growth items
page with reserve savings plans over
three to five years so how the budget
gap is growing or we've said is a more
detailed breakdown of the MTF s
assumptions will be included with the
2019-20 budget of all their response
doesn't sound like we're doing what the
recommendation is asking for and again
included sensitivity analysis of the
impact we've got a sensitivity of
analysis of the context operas to be
modeled and shared with members to fall
back to settings but we're not
necessarily published on the face of the
mt m s report and again I'm looking at
the top line we recommend for
transparency to the public this was
about so I just want confirmation that
if it's not on the face of the Mt
report the analysis will be within a
report and will be available to the
public not as members there's some
situations on that yeah I don't know if
we're to go further down we're just
asked to be aware of all the assumptions
as you aware we have second Idol members
and sliders part the member away day we
did which again some of the scenario
analysis around I take I mean I take
your point about transparency I think we
throw that as take the budget to be
agreed powerful counsel we're
recommending a certain set of options
which we're recommending to Council and
we would necessarily include all of the
sensitivity analysis as part of that
report so we're clear about how we've
arrived at the conclusions and
recommendations were making as part of
the budget at Baltimore and how those
have been arrived at but we wouldn't
necessarily sort of do a whole set of
options as part of the actual formal
budget report so that that was the
conclusion when we arrived up and yeah
I'm I'm happy that we sort of met the
alright orbiters happy that we've done
that but obviously we haven't been
completed the value money assessment for
the 1819 budget setting so episodes
though we're not satisfied whatever
reason I'm sure that will be raised
again as part of for
always take another how we do it again
next year but I think we had initial
discussions about what we were planning
and I don't think there's anything I
just have concerns that this may not be
my note
I understand the difficulties of
budgeting punishing a year ahead then
five years ahead and providing that
something was gonna be accurate that far
far ahead
although it's very short to medium term
my concern is the isn't really meeting
what was required by the recommendation
with sorry relation sorry I know now go
back to the early wedding relations the
fact that there's peace some concerns
about how and measuring of whether or
not we would that cost savings will be
achieved or not like ie we have
addressed those it would appear I've
read those it I just think he goes a
little bit with the one in front of
nothing together with perhaps lot if
we're not if we're not able to write the
detail there or not for how we can
provide the shoreless that will be and
that we're on target ground savings from
projected savings if it all fighting
fatigue the detail the dirt from a
spring the recommendations that's the
concern all need to put down make sure
it's recorded I've got those concerns
respective the recommendations we made
with the aim of improving the council's
processes so we weren't saying there's
anything fundamentally wrong you know
obviously concluded arrangements were
adequate but they were areas that could
be improved in the process I think the
key thing really for us is probably
around the savings the first
recommendation in terms of the second
one I think with two elements of that so
we talked about the council tax Loveland
I think the first element is called both
again more important one in terms of
just having that profile breakdown you
can see when the different issues
hitting so I don't think from our
perspective their fundamental issues the
areas where we think the MTFs process
and the savings management process could
be strengthened and we'll look at it
this year okay and on this little take
you boy yeah I thought of that on the
point further down so the next on
retrieving the tubular savings need
about the medium-term we just took about
six steps I'll get sprawl performance
measures now I understand what secret to
doesn't mean you must simply it say we
are trying to or do your best to
overtime should have we been able to set
targets for these measures it talks
about achievement of targets but you're
not really the answer doesn't say if
it's if we were able to set targets for
performance basis or someone or key ones
anomalies or whatever is where it was in
the processes and in Greece there wasn't
a clear measure we find that those have
been reported - and effective as a thank
you
six point seven has invested point eight
comment there especially the very last
line we made similar eken the
recommendations in the previous year
sounds like the criticism because we
haven't done what we should have done
I think you miss especially around this
that all decreasing other committees in
terms of yeah what all do at work we
should do around IT and I think it is
control environment yeah as we spoke
about previous committee meetings who
have had a lack of audit resource and we
haven't had a full complement the staff
since October of this year and what we
said at the last committee is actually
we have prioritized the audit plan for
this year so all the priority one wall
is that Warne must have to provide an
already opinion for the year will be
undertaking we weren't completely would
have plan in its entirety so but we will
complete necessary work to provide my
opinion for a year which feeds into the
annual governance team so all the
weather is necessary for me to complete
in terms of providing an opinion on the
council's control them on what we've
done there are some like priority to
audience that don't necessary
inform my opinion mechapls control about
their like nice orders to do to pass
improve the control of our room but are
not necessary for my overall opinion so
all here what is that I need to do will
be completed what about next year it's a
new audit plan we now have a full
complement of staff so the audit plan
which will come to this community in May
we would look to deliver it in its
entirety so we're not likely to have
that same comment we made similar
recommendations the previous year no and
I think there's things to be
understanding that there's a new and
already plans put together it's
basically it changes over time in terms
of the risks perceived by the council
you hope to achieve you already plan but
you prioritize it in ways like these the
ones I must do these are ones I might
like to do if I don't do it it's not
going to change my opinion control
tomorrow okay sweetles it was on place
six point six the PATA arrangements with
the central housing I know these kind of
reforms I've had answers and I think the
answers still the same exact right
before is because so it's percent the
recommendation which is that we that we
confirm the arrangement of HMRC
concerning the the vit recovery with
sanctuary in our response we've got
sentries on external audits have given
the necessary or shortages that they are
happy the scheme is compliant with HMRC
guidance that doesn't seem a very strong
assurance maybe we've got no legal basis
to to hold somebody else auditors for
advice I don't have is there an HMRC
agreement for this scheme or not what
sort of assurances were was received
from centuries auditors
let's go back ten years or so and as we
said before we have been not been able
to find the original source
documentation related to the scheme from
our side of things I think the comment
about the assurance from centuries
perspective is able to have their
accounts audited separately and that
they evade would have the auditors from
their progeny Lackey that they that the
scheme was compliant what we did say was
we would have a further check to see if
we could find any further information so
we are still we have done an initial
review and we still haven't found any
further guidance we have got our new
technical council starting next week so
that may be something we are able to
dedicate a bit more resource to
following up again before the audit for
this year but I'm not expecting that we
are going to find any more source
documentation so I think that might be a
risk that we may have to live with all
their I deem it to be quite a low risk
given that the amount of time that's
passed and then it's not been an issue
identified in the past ten years
relation to this okay also a team on
scale bothered of our time policy there
are only 400 people after 20 years so it
is a potential liability syllable quite
thank you thank you feels really wait
[Music]
all right so the recommendation is that
the updates provided in the monitor
indicates the external auditors
recommendation she notice says that
melted I 27 the external auditor report
consider the report the section 1 v 1
officer during members attention to the
certification of claims and returns
annual report to 1718 the healthy
benefits claim value total value at
sixteen point eight million the we're a
small number of areas that were
identified and buzzes in we are then
compile them and I'd like to carry out
further testing work this mistakes more
is also on their part and that the
projected Erin that's sorry amount of
jierou that was associated with the
sixteen point eight million pound claim
for 790
so it's not a material amount in
relation to the amount of the claim
however as a result of the additional
testing about that and we carried out
the fee associated with work because
obviously risen from the original Antony
and we aged Whitney right going forward
just to mention that video and I think I
mean I guess just for context the
housing benefit assessment process is
very complex assessment and therefore
it's uncommon to find errors in
assessments so most of our clients Vichy
qualification letters and I guess just
in addition to be a very small reduction
subs that are including the audit work
we did also issue what the vacation
exits the didn't you plead and that
would have some of the other areas that
we identified where we were able to
fully amend the claim because we
couldn't confirm that that was the total
of the error so in that situation we
extrapolate the error based on the
population the sample will be tested and
when we report that animator to the DWP
and then the DWP make a decision as to
whether whether they're going to recover
any of the subsidy that's reported in
those extrapolations
I would say that generally they do tend
to do that now I think is our experience
and they do tend to write those sums but
there wasn't anything significant and a
few other
remember in terms of those amounts I
think worked out that the percentage
errors was no point not for true but I
think that's only on the error on the
actual the mainland yeah other errors
that we can't amend for that we then
reporting our extrapolations in
qualification later because we can only
amend if we test it on it's fine if all
of the population therefore she will
look the amenities of nice and accurate
and we've only test the sample cases
which is the only what we do then we can
to mainly because you can say that
that's an accurate
[Music]
thank you any other questions
counsel apart you know it was like the
only Chris I really have was various
recreational fears being explained quite
well by just putting to to ask around
the this is just a check for the DWP we
gonna be if we found it
errors which might have been in favor of
the claimant would have affected and
that those resulted in increasing their
claim or not in the work we do here the
DWP is own interesting benefits if
you've underpaid a claimant soon then
that's because it's worth three terms of
correcting the assessment subsequently
equally you will become broken chains
the claimants clearly but the DWP is
only interested where you've overpaid
because that means you've over claimed
such a difficult a DWP and that's that's
what the purpose of the PM certification
that we do to check that the DWP is paid
you the right amount of subsidy in
relation to the housing benefit you paid
out to claimants
so when we do our testing and we find in
situation where Clinton has been
underpaid the case will be the claimant
does not lose out that will receive
nothing yesterday any further questions
item 7 the recommendation is that the
certification and flames and returns any
report be noted that no two item 8 is
external audit audit and pause to
consider the report the section 1 5 1
officer presenting the external auditors
annual plan covering the audience of
2019 so yeah that's probably all I was
going to say at this stage but anybody's
see what I'd like to don't take the
report straight but I think that will be
helpful is just to really talk me
through the risks that we've identified
in relation to both audited financial
statements and I value the money
conclusion a lot of its highlights
lenders on materiality levels that want
to take dollars worth two antipholuses
confident that those levels are
appropriate and see if I can take
members to first of all PG seven and
AIDS if it was caught eight point eight
and on those two pages with Saturday
with the respective identified in
relation to our audited financial
statements the first two risks are what
we call fraud risks which is where we're
saying that there could potentially be
incentive for management to report
critical financial statements risk
there's actually no change really from
the risk of if identified between
previous year but all we've done is
separated out the risk from the general
risk that we had ninety five this
demonstrates a fraud an era where we
undertake procedures around journals
accounting estimates we also look at the
overall controlled environments of the
authority but we've separated out the
main area where we think that we could
be manifested and that's in terms of
incorrect capitalization of revenue
expenditure the reason we identified
that is because most of the adjustments
or areas that we could see in the
accounts would only move expenditure or
income between years and as local
government financing is undertaken over
a more of a medium-term period as you
obviously see from your meeting to infer
national strategy the only thing that
actually moves expenditure out of
revenue in their stops impacting on
council tax the general fund balance is
if you shift it into capital and
therefore you can fund it through
capital resources therefore we
particularly focus on capital additions
in year and make sure that as capital
addition
a genuinely Kathleen nature and
therefore can be fairly cut for
resources and shouldn't be charged the
revenue account so that's the particular
area and thus that's the risk that we
see most local authorities and for any
degree of level of capital spend so
you're not unusual in that sense it's
just where we see the risk manifesting
itself in local authorities we then
identified pension liability valuation
and valuation of land among the
buildings as both higher inherent risk
so we're not saying as a specific
significant risk around those but on
both of those they are extremely light
figures in the council's balance sheets
and they are both subject to estimation
and judgments and therefore we'd want to
check additional procedures around both
of those to make sure that the
assumptions that have been used in
forming those estimates are reasonable
and that the inputs and those
calculations are also supportable we've
been also I - or you could I just post
something on that particular point we
say the thicket is very large is that
County no no no that's that's your
figures that's a pension liability in
rocks with district councils accounts
and the people with property plant and
equipment in your accounts so are we
having that in 31 million its it's the
liabilities has it accounted for so it's
calculated as as an accounting figure
and I know there's often a lot of
debates about that figure in local
authority accounts so it is calculated
future liability using a number of
assumptions and various accounting
standards it's just you know now I get
the impression from that that we're
behind with our payments into the
pension fund but last year it was held
at the Ordnung maybe that we're up to
date you know it's not it's not a
liability in that sense it's not saying
you owe 31 you know how you were behind
that back there - I mean depends on pain
that it's the future estimated liability
the actuarial calculate annual employer
contributions that the council needs to
make to make sure the fund is
appropriately funded and that would be
for all the council's
contribute to its expansion you
understand it all now because you're
making the contributions in line we've
got the actually assets okay and the
next three oh we just we've identified a
right now it's like changing the risk
for you we've still got three financial
statements as last year was the first
year that the tense the consolidated
green gate we're trading we we have that
as high-risk last year because there was
more chance of error in year one there's
still obviously transferring the
consolidation but we think that's
reduced because we're already going
through one of these processing relation
like that the last two are new ones the
first one is the spine a steam capacity
which I'm sure the members of you could
say they're they're obviously a number
of key finance officers departing the
council this year and also some key
people going on returning to leave some
of those will be after the accounts
process but also we've got tutti capi
technical accountant who are actually
going on maternity leave in April 19
which you've got obviously before we
start the audits and June accounts
closed down process so for the council
that clearly represents the risk and
obviously the knock-on effect is that it
represents a risk for us so we'll be
monitoring closely what the council is
doing in terms of filling those gaps and
putting in place proper arrangements to
make sure that the the sufficient
capacity to produce the accounts and to
support the audit process but we did
think it was worth flagging because it's
quite a number of people it's not just
one person there's new things at the
moment so I think you just created risk
and we've been discussing that with the
last risk that we've identified which is
a new on is the new accounting standards
so there's new standards they've been
implemented here in relation to
financial instruments and accounting for
revenue from contracts I think it's
important the case when it takes an
assessment of the impact of those
accounting standards and will need to
disclose their accounts I think many
councils have started trying to take
that assessments of conclusion it's
unlikely to be material but that process
needs to be gone
and obviously we're expecting patience
with Riley supposed to support those
assessments and Greengate we're trading
mainly to specifically consider revenue
from contracts so the separately in
terms of having potential impacts sorry
another point on that with the asset
review that's going on at the moment we
could be affected then from the revenue
from contracts as a later date
potentially the other legs I mean it
there's very specific rules around how
rs.15 is being applied for the public
sector and so in terms of thinking about
its revenue from contracts with
customers so that's why a green gateway
may be impacted and if you have future
arrangements that are similar then you
would need to consider those but it's
not something that's probably going to
impact you significant this year I
wouldn't have thought but I'm not know
do something include - yeah going back
to the finance team capacity how far are
we along with them taking action to fill
the vacancies so the key is that we as
vegetable trust they're always the yeah
we actually pulled his technical
accountant well and we've got someone
starting on Monday and curry so she's
already been in for a few days hand over
and she's yeah an experienced local
government and waterside had significant
expensive pony counts that she used to
work a lot of years ago so I've got
confidence that she's more than capable
of leading and doing the developments of
work in terms of that pet needs
boneheaded finance while real planning
cigars recruitment and imminently on
that and as you say I stepped up and my
time from three days to five days partly
and to cover some of that capacity so
that's been one of the mitigations
and covering Matt's well and in terms of
the yogurty and Management Accountants
so mo tradesmen who will be going on
maternity leave we've actually sort of
planned in some of that in terms of how
the audit work undertaken so we've
actually moved some of the key sort of
testing that we can earlier in the
process so they'll actually be able to
and it feels the most hospital in our
maternity leave them we obviously make
sure there's adequate and handover in
terms of an interim arrangements and to
complete see that work to fruition for
the final audit testing so I think we've
taken the necessary action as far as we
can but yes and there will be some
interim is also quite and to cover those
two interested to us that we say we are
doing more work in sort of next week I
think we've got resources in March and
also some more resources in April before
those people depart to try and do our
substantive work that we would not only
do after the accounts produce so weekly
often afford as much as we can and
working with the finance team to
mitigate that risk as much as we can
okay okay and then we just like to draw
your attention to materiality which is
summarized on page and I but then
there's a little bit more detail of page
21
so it's eight point two one
Newport so that's basically just set the
materiality levels that we are doctors
doing our audits so you set an overall
materiality level of 0.7 to six million
but then we actually undertake our audit
work to a slightly to a lower level and
that's to make sure that we build in
sort of catering for potentially senior
errors we can set that Thresh because
that performance material thresholded
add a 1% or 2% we set that at 2% which
is the maximum level that we can set
that out and then our performs
materiality we can set about a 50% or
75% because of the level of errors that
we've found in previous years and also I
think because of the additional risk and
changing the finance team we feel that
we have to set that at 50% of this year
which does drive additional audit work
because it means that our testing
thresholds are lower in terms of the
samples that we test and then we agree
that we report any unadjusted
differences above 36,000 pounds to the
audit committee and we do ask the audit
community when I just finished going
through the item to confirm they're
comfortable with those materiality
levels the last thing I really wanted to
mention was the value of any conclusion
members to page 8 point 18 and 8.19
don't eat all the areas we would look at
is reset potential we've taken to
consider brexit future service provision
and we have completed our value from in
conclusion and we were satisfied that
the council is considering that
adequately we also identified that we
think the asset delivery program which
other serve members just mentioned as an
area that we need to do some more work
on us
a significant risk we will also keep an
eye on issue that the councillors have
in relation to IT failures and the
issues I think that contingency funds of
work well and it hasn't impacted on
service delivery but we just need to
keep an eye on that until the end of the
year but therefore we have identified as
I say one significant risk in relation
to the countess's asset strategy it will
be looking at the governance
arrangements around the acid delivery
program and also how individual projects
are assess the financial viability and
so that's really the risk that we'll be
looking at in conclusion and I guess the
only other thing to note is in relation
to the fee that we have noted at the end
section on page eight point three five
but there's possible increase our fee as
a result of the lower Saxon threshold
that we've had to apply because the
errors and previous years
also the fact that there are groups can
switch you're not reflecting the scale
feeders step back PSA a picks out the
section number of years ago and also the
vfm significant risk that we've
identified around the asset development
strategy
we haven't quantified the amount of that
additional fee at the moment to release
about episodes will start to submit that
work in a bit more detail so we can go
back with detailed breakdowns of hours
you've touched on the asset delivery are
you liaison with leads on this because
they're the consultants we're using and
they're to a large extent guiding us and
working with us on value for money best
options and all this or tapes so while
I'm not saying that we're blind in this
issue we have specifically pulled in
people with
to some competence together so are you
working with them in this respect or or
is it two separate operations we
wouldn't necessarily work with them I
think the fact that the counselors
brought was any of this part of an
affection your arrangements your
arrangements are basically to identify
where you have maybe gaps and skills or
need for sports and you've brought in
that additional support so that's
probably as far as our assessment would
go to say we're comfortable that the
council has assessed you know the
governance structures that it needs how
it needs to support he needs to make its
decisions make informed decisions the
right information and that's really as
far as we go we wouldn't go as far as an
even two years with everything Leslie
the specific issue that we felt we need
to which I think it's very unlikely
people say coming they've been quite
specific in in setting out the the
financial structure and the route that
we go down so I mean they have done a
huge amount of background work into the
the best financial route to go not
saying we've agreed with them 100% but
we certainly have been you know
listening to them and the way they've
done it because every terms of doing
this sort of project before will where
we haven't been through yeah because we
said investment board of C we can take
professional advice and obviously we
have used and please and we've worked in
special events the modeling is done and
we comes to share the documentation
directly ultimately the accounts
appendices still rest of us as council
so we can't so part of the
accountability to things not is you're
making the stays with us so we've taken
the advice on please but ultimately it's
Austin Council it's going to be
accountable for them
yeah I think that's what the okay
thank you I've just read a couple of
areas one is you vote you break these
obviously I just want to just emphasize
a couple of things the first one is on
page eight point seven the incorrect
capitalization of revenue expenditure
you said there's no change in the risk
we got then there's public risk and it's
obviously the relation to two am marking
revenue as capital it must be I suppose
obviously there were there is a
electioneering that there was an
identification last year where we as
accounts were told to reclassify some
revenue expenditure is capital what
levels they were worried rounding
relation to I team so we've got it you
ain't it
there's a history that we have a have
had a problem in the past around this as
well but you still think the risk is and
change despite that say where we had to
be classified and an element of the
revenue I think that was it wasn't a
fortunate sort of error in that it was
you know planned it was just about that
I think that it's more than accounting
judgment thirdly obviously the project
was intended to be comfortable in nature
from now set but actually when we looked
at the nature of some of the spend it
was an element that actually review we
was classified as revenue so I don't
know what's any more but and I don't
think there's an inherent sort of
underlying risk as you say it's just
that is an area with its policy sorry
difficult okay I didn't intend suggest
it was fully involved you know I'm just
anybody forget yeah it might be that it
could be an inherent risk rather than
the fortunate risk as well perhaps in
the way it just was done I think we we
always testify as a fraud with epic
because
significant from from our perspective
because as I said there is it's probably
the one one of the very few areas a lot
of government accounts where there was a
genuine incentive to potentially do that
and so we always viewed as a heightened
risk area and also there is a degree of
judgment some areas very clearly revenue
or capital and then there's always a
little gray area in between where you
know you need to look at the standards
quite carefully the type of expenditure
and former judgments and so we obviously
focus on those one particular way and
and that mistake last year was was that
a gray area that I'm sure whether it was
kept for revenue yes I mean in the
transfer of the IT system to as an
element if you're running and I think
and yeah some of that was classified as
capital but I think some of the actual
the circles involved to be capitalized
that was the element that was then sheet
is revenue it's something I just brought
up because there is Duffy has a further
capital budget hundred thousand pound
for a server room in the budget it has
something else available for my thought
right the only other thing I think I've
been raised
I just went dead I think I know what he
means but we're using the word
sustainable resource deployment can we
just have a make sure I do that with
these please unfortunate is the wording
used in the NAO codebook so that's why
we've used that but it basically means
kind of financial stability plain
English so Adrian basically look at the
immediately upon a strategy we look at
the level of woodchip gap within that
the level of savings that have been
identified the track record of deliver
savings and that's only for money though
step back to 8.1 I can 4.30
so our video - we have to take somebody
else on after me one and so we and we've
been through a human exercise shall we
get best value for money so essentially
as part of that the tender and that
video came in was then the the wire and
one so that day under that it was human
we got the bands go which I we should do
that with the full order then so yeah
all of it is subject to them yesterday
and yeah approach but just that those
two elements are treated separately so
and I went to a separate process but it
would actually voluntary class and as
part of that process so that would be
clinical education you students the PSA
a contract but from fishier 1819 isn't a
longer into that contract so every
council has to be its own particular
process to fight for teachers to do that
claim justification for the account so
we know would be similar over life as
those figures of clearly accounts and so
we and the tables were to in assurance
and those figures but to be honest the
claims at education with
anyway so there was I mean we undertook
a procurement exercising behalf of three
overseas broken classes and Brentford to
secure best value for money and their
lowest corner video well I never heard
of them before it's just under four
counties he practices yeah yeah
why try and go many many years ago so
the recommendation is that the external
auditors annual audit plan for 2019 1890
be noted I - 9 - note the external
auditors all in committee briefing and
provide response to the key questions
within it thickness item is really just
first emerging remember descending and I
say there are numbers going through
those morning and even if anyone's way
any questions thank you say useful make
sure will be people travel we supposed
to be able to do it's a very but we have
our answers to these these questions
item 10 consider the report to the
assistant director democratic services
providing members with an update on
completed completed all the engagements
delivery of the audit plan and progress
in implementing audit thank you my
report provides an overview to work
complete since April but all the
presenters findings and respective
auditor views completed at the past
three months five back in and to be
really physio are three months and spare
to say and completely a further six
audit reviews be number appendix one a
light touch briefly on the audit rear of
our insurance administration
arrangements I just received a limb to
the shore and rating this this piece
work turn out to be a wine your brain
wide-ranging piece of work
issues concerns which have been
discussed at the senior leadership team
the major areas of concerns for us Lisa
we don't appear to have a single
complete record of our assets there's
some uncertainty insists that everything
that should be insured is insured but
there's no evidence that suggests that
our key assets are not insured also we
identify we don't have effective
inspection regimes in place regard to
our assets as a result we could be
non-compliant with the terms of
decisions of our insurance cover also
puts the counselor at risk from claims
for negligence should imagine Institute
injury occur and we look at local press
that as I'm invited positive there are
some shortcomings in its own inspections
arrangements in relation to camera
forward work this is limited to the work
undertaken by the compliance team
compliance team and continues to deliver
catchable savings for the authority
that's been ninety nine thousand pounds
worth of savings in relation to council
tax this tends to relate to single
person discounts that acclaimed for
didn't think where there's actually more
than one person at that property we also
identified new new areas of in relation
to envy our business rights where we not
previously build a number of companies
and we've been identifying that over two
hundred twelve thousand pounds worth of
new building arrangements
lastly I'd like to talk about progress
made by service departments in
implementing with recommendations
since concerns were raised with the
senior leadership team services
department are now making good progress
in implementing board recommendations we
look at appendix four
we actually but at my me a total 51
rings listed over 25 so this sets a list
of our library combinations as such and
Jim's taking a review of these order
recommendations and it's a considered
opinion that our further 25 of these
recommendations and now being permitted
and their flag that they leave mark so
they will be taken up in turn around so
we are making good progress in
implementing and with recommendations
soon as we raised our concerns with the
senior leadership team to take any
questions I want to do just about a
minute um yeah I know she doesn't this
be in the reports and false at the one
available page view towards theory we've
just really read the alleged contract
because we're talking about some you've
got limited assurance around the
contractor not meeting these operational
sorry thought we quietly what other
specified obligations and regulations
could be lots of things I suppose I
think the facilities that we're saying
that this contract is coming to an end
so it's saying that they are doing some
work I'm wondering what the risk is that
but I'll try to radiate not to be fair
up on the phone often the answer may
well be in this rec hall when I just
can't understand where it is within it
but I'll try to find assurance is though
that we have in place procedures which
will allow us to make sure that within
our we satisfy the aspects we didn't
look at the end of life of the contract
the limited issues around health and
safety and fire assessments and could I
come back on me that I've got personas
that they aren't being reported
elsewhere there might be going to be two
members on the way that council mr. mrs.
Mason taking an interest in chemical for
instance we've been to the public and
here he's got progressional knees have
not been on these has been reported to
member on the floor that means that
these members and has not been including
this work that's about building
condition contractor requirements or
under wife I'm not aware that it's been
reported to me I'm on the review
committee as well but although it's been
discussed and talked about the review
committee I think of the last review
committee meeting a councillor Castle
Hazelwood I think we all know that
correct about maybe look at the
buildings we're told and
we are not doing that so certainly not
within the review committee at the
moment to look at that see that's
happening so I'm not sure where that
that is happening
Vora committee if it's happening by a
portfolio holder or something else could
that be reported back to us because
otherwise we well we've got two to three
years to go comport remember the exact
date twenty to twenty two years three
and that's not very long relationship to
us potentially either letting out the
building's gain in a poor condition or
receiving them back in a poor condition
or conditions they is unsatisfactory
after sailing because consider email yet
yes sorry I think the ad is keeping a
very close eye on that from comments
that he's made but I think we should
query that again it really doesn't
matter yeah is that through the cherries
that something come here or something we
could ask review to look at it but I
mean you're raising it in this in this
committee it's like hey you're ready to
come back yeah and then he could be
provided you know post this meeting
[Music]
everything free against me outright
gonna bawl me out because I don't think
we've got the detail of exactly welcome
surly might just be forty between
committees yes so we'll really fit
within this committee so it doesn't fall
to tell you anything
thank you that was that one first we
should also be anything to attend on
that good yes it could and the portfolio
holder just to be clear are we and
asking him to attend that
this crazy or - yes yes thank you um job
it was or some on the page it was we
rethought into the progress of all the
recommendations sort of there's been
interest rate we're actually above his
head not an I assume that what I'm going
to say they've been raised with with
departments it was just the age of some
of these getting on 2016-17 sorry 7.19
for instance ears in general that's the
first page to go through they started
2016-17 and we've got revised in dates
31st of March 19 now when the ax
breathing fermentation date originally
was 31st of July 17 that's the first one
there's an example there's some which
I've deleted those are some would you on
going there on there is and I think it's
has been answered reasonably well by
default executive sounds bad a lot of
the ones be played you say to be new I'm
driving the older one the other ones
seem to be sticking around and also
there's some such as the essay one which
has been we've seen we will be able
taken by the insurance the thorns
insurance assurance and but if we then
have a plague of eight months time when
it started some time ago asset
management there so 1718 asset
management a greedy implementation date
31st of March 18 which instead we say we
say never minutes ago the fire station
31st is dry now we're saying this
recommendation closely links legal
services and the esses management team
and then it's got further down testing
of the new systems due to start early
February and I suppose it seems like
this is just think we seem to be going
over and on and it's something you've
raised but it's just easy
yeah
meetings with our clients that which we
set agreed implementation days we asked
them to be realistic but sometimes there
are taking overtaken by events and they
look like they appear to be hanging
around for ages and ages it's their best
guess of when when things will be likely
to be implemented by earnest but
sometimes it's just take made by events
on hand and we get pushback but you know
so people to be careful nor though
they're being pushed back to here two
years three years create critical them
you'd expect them to basically set
implementation day of life one to two
months or even less than them so if it's
critical spirit system if it's gonna
fall apart or it sends a serious risk to
the council you know in expecting to be
familiar with in short time scales but
these are others that actually I'm not
that critical to the overall control
environment so this way is that it's a
dead Paulo city we'd like to see
something happen but you know it's not
critical to the counters at home yeah
and also then on page as another I'll
leave you after this buddy I don't
really appreciate gonna have been
answered and then you've given a good
answer on page ten point three two for
instance the tool we've raised neutrons
arrangements elsewhere about the problem
they may or may not be they could be
problems with it because we have offered
SFA's and we've got a tricycle
part of a new insurance requirements
Twitter or cover is still relevant an
essay is properly described we've said
there is a problem there we've got an
ingredient annotation but I have thirty
first of all verse 19 is that the point
at which we are expecting to have full
assurance that everything we have is
covered and covered
yes point to which the insurance is due
for renewal so that's the obviously we
need to make sure the information is
complete I mean in relation to the
question Randy asset register I mean I
think it's an iterative process and we
did do some assurance work sitting
around the financial asset registers to
ensure that all is complete and I'll
technical captain last year they did
quite a bit of work to make sure that
yeah our asset register was complete I
think the issue is beyond an identified
and more recent audit work is
particularly around fact that we've
still got three different asset
registers which always quite
specifically different purposes so from
a legal point of view from an operation
all sort of maintenance point again from
a financial point of view I think in an
ideal world there would be some one
version of the truth but I think in
reality and as I say that because
they're quite long and complicated and
documents and they're all being used
slightly different purposes it's not a
straight forward thing to put them all
into like two one and into one version
so I think we're investigating whether
there's some kind of self-preservation
that might help us and do that maintain
that throwing forward but it's not
something that we can implement
overnight so I think that's why it was
inevitably the slightly more complex
issues that do take a bit more time to
resolve and as you say when there's
things that can be implemented quite
quickly that base on
comment on an IBM recommendation is
quite quickly but it is those areas
actually could require sort of a bit of
project work have more detailed work to
actually implement the solution they
never to completely long run as Mike
pointed out I think maybe it has been a
slightly unrealistic expectation at some
of the implementation dates when they
originally but more that we could do
this in a quick timeframe
we actually have been able to but that's
not to say we don't recognize importance
of doing that I think we just have to be
you slightly realistic about about the
endpoint that we need to get to in a way
that needs to be done to get there
that's we need to be looking carefully
at our implementation dates in life and
be more realistic yeah I think that's a
performance I've been on done on to page
10.5 so we've got completed all these
announcements salary obviously they love
these are peppered the complete days why
do they still show the assurance rating
is that what it was at the time yes
limit limited output yeah that that
close to the assurance ratings at the
time unless we're going to go back and
rethink a similar piece of work and then
actually that that base what it is at
that time yeah yeah we mean obviously in
implementing the recommendations you if
you if you would rework at you pretty
get a different insurance rating because
if who's obviously they would
implemented the recommendations to
address the concerns but until we do a
follow-up piece of work and then once
one receive it that's a different
mission run politics so it's a rating
provider that time okay
in Iceland the recommendation is one of
the update on delivering the 2018 ninety
one day and we noted the conclusions and
results from completed order engagements
in Pence's turns 3b no two and three
that the updated state of audit
recommendations in appendix four be
noted that noted